si le niveau global de la circulation du
virus est aujourd'hui comparable à celui
du début de l'automne dernier des
signaux d'alert se font jour dans
certains territoires et je tenais à
m'exprimer sur ce point en occitanie en
nouvelles aquitaine nous constatons des
hausses parfois sensible de la
circulation du virus sur cette région
la nouvelle aquitaine le taux de
reproduction du virus le fameux air est
repassé au-dessus de 1 ce qui signifie
que l'épidémie y gagne de nouveau du
terrain
et ouais ça ça ça nous inquiéter alors
merci prisca d'être avec nous prisca
thévenot porte parole de la république
en marche
merci et fabrice di vizio magnifique en
petit schumi tête il a trouvé son style
et son nom mais vraiment il a trouvé son
créneau vestimentaire est son credo
jessica merci fabrice d'être aussi
élégant jallet de retour alors est ce
que vous trouvez que le déconfinement et
réussit ici autour de la table oui oui
j'ai gardé ce nom pourquoi pas du tout
ça a été mal préparée c'est n'importe
quoi les gens notamment les jeunes ont
l'impression que le virus est partie que
c'est fini on fait n'importe quoi les
terrasses sont pleines
il ya même des terrasses quasiment à
l'intérieur pour moi c'est un haut
risque
ça flambe dans le sud-ouest et j'ai peur
que la flambée s'étendent partout
totalement ratée ah oui vous avez porté
m 4e vague quand je dirais peur d'une
quatrième vague alors à tout droit on
n'y ait pas de morts alors il ya des
endroits dans le monde où il ya déjà la
quatrième vague au vietnam par exemple
c'est bien aussi
ah oui et non parce qu'alors plus moi
j'ai vécu lequel il n'est pas très
longtemps de façon dramatique donc je
peux vous dire que free si vous avez
déjà vu mais surtout moi je vais partir
ma femme inconsciente et emmenée par le
samu et donc j'étais un peu énervé sur
le sujet oui je pense qu'il faut faire
vraiment attention je pense
effectivement que j'ai la raison quand
on voit ce qui se passe à paris quand on
voit des terrasses
il est évident que pour voilà il n'y a
aucune distance et arrivons pas les
masques et c'est normal ça fait 18 mois
qu'on est con et enfermé donc je
comprends que les gens veuillent
jardinage mois promet j'ai été en
terrasse ont vu tvac cdg le comité
peut-être que je sois pas là où il ya
plusieurs idées noires
je pense vraiment en train de parler de
vous finalement c'est un peu moi non je
plaisante non je pense vraiment qu'il
faut faire attention et je pense que si
les gens sont pas vraiment mobilisé et
qu'on fait pas attention est vraiment
attention
la quatrième balle a pu arriver c'est
vrai que melbourne vient d'être servis
pour sept jours donc ça rend format un
peu partout dans le monde donc on ne
s'en est pas sorti de l'auberge vous
vous targuez sk alors j'entends c'est
ces sujets ou non que ça nous a fait
peur ce qu'a dit gabriela pas un alors
et c'est à relativiser
oui il ya deux régions qui sont un peu
plus surveillés et plus en alerte que le
raison de la france sont des clés mais
on reste quand même sur des niveaux et
des touches foot et quand je vous
demande mérité en train de répondre âge
et est très centré sur quels sont les
dorés de l'occitanie la nouvelle extend
merci à bosse et j'ai bien regardé elle
est prête pour présenter des miss france
et non mais je voyais benjamin castaldi
inquiète donc les foules à travers
champs de le voir parce que lui ne vous
voit pas et donc pris ce cas lisez donc
oui à ces deux régions qui sont plus en
vigilance que les autres mais les taux
d'incidence et les taux
d'hospitalisation et de l'animation
reste quand même largement en dessous de
ce qu'on a pu constater avant et moi
c'est sûr ça qu'il faut qu'on se rassure
quand même c'est qu'effectivement depuis
une dizaine de jours on a desserré les
mesures avec l'élargissement du couvre
feu avec la réouverture des thés raté de
certains lieux de culture et en
parallèle on voit que les indicateurs
sont quand même bon et j'ai continué à
diminuer
on a le nombre de réac qui sont à moins
de 3000 le nombre d'hospitalisations qui
sont aux alentours de 16 mille et ça
quand même globalement oui il ya des
écarts oui mais globalement c'est aussi
et surtout du grâce à la
responsabilisation des français il
respecte les dix ans ciation social qui
continue à porter le masque qui continue
à faire attention et en parallèle et ça
il faut vraiment le souligner c'est
aussi la vaccination qui avance sert aux
morts c'est l'art de souffler sa tempe
ariz mais c'est quoi
elle fait des tours puisque non mais on
n'a pas arrêté de dire ça risquait rien
juste alors dans deux minutes on aura
pris des vidéos qui a ramené son dossier
d'air généralement une très mauvaise
nouvelle je dois d'abord avoir les noms
là nicolas pernikoff pour vous ça n'a
cessé un loupé pour moi c'est un loupé
mais ça on n'en ai jamais parlé mais
pour une simple mais tout simplement
parce rythme très loin on est très loin
de l'imiter collective et regarder
israël j'enlève mes s'est passé pas du
tout mais on va regarder ils ont ils ont
arrêté le pass ils sont en train de
réfléchir à peut-être arrêter le masque
mais pas dans les pas à l'intérieur des
restaurants et aujourd'hui regarder dans
la rue les gens ont mis leur masse c'est
à dire que maintenant les gens ils
rentrent dans les endroits et les
demandes au restaurant s'ils ont un
masque parce qu'ils ont même pu le
masque dont quitterait pas ses taux une
quatrième bague mais la france ne
supportera pas un nouvel isolement c'est
à dire le sérail du match en restant je
vais y aller et fabrice sur toi est-ce
que des confinement est raté est-ce que
les confinements et râper balleux
déconfinement il n'est pas fini surtout
c'est à dire réalité c'est à dire qu'en
fait on peut pas considérer que le
confinement est terminée puisqu'il reste
des restrictions sur speed mais parce
que c'est un autre problème
les matches des restrictions cinéma ce
contexte là et j'espère que les salaires
et de masques oui c'est de pouvoir faire
quand même qu'on a encore on n'est pas
toujours pas les intérieurs ne sont pas
ouverts les salles de sport ne sont pas
ouvertes je vous rappelle qu'il ya quand
même tout un tas de restrictions bien
sûr alors ça implique jetterait un point
ça interroge sur un point sur
déconfinement oui belle et que en fait
comme personne ne lit rien personne
n'écoute rien je viens ici depuis un an
quasiment maintenant et finalement c'est
intéressant parce que j'écoutais tout à
l'heure les uns et les autres mais au
bout d'un moment en fait c'est du dogme
c'est de la foi c'est-à-dire combattre
les dogmes moi je veux combattre la
raison à discuter mais combattre les
dogues moi je fais pas quand on vous
explique que ben finalement les gens
sont entassés à l'extérieur mais combien
de fois faudra-t-il vous dire qu'il n'ya
pas de contamination à l'extérieur 1 c 0
1% et que même le président de la
république l'erreur commise puisqu'on a
été confiné aux grandes nouvelles à
l'extérieur cette fois le dernier mais
ya pas de contamination extérieure
pourrait faire non de la tête tout ce
que vous voulez enfin dans l'âge qui à
fait normal d'ailleurs l'ultime
il arrive un moment donné oui moi je
suis pas censée lutter contre des doses
pas là pour ça je suis pas la chance
aspects de la religion quoi ah oui c'est
de la science et de la raison c'est de
lui sur le droit mais c'est du 2 mai ça
c'est du dogme quand j'entends dire mais
vous imaginez les gens en terrasse et
bien ne porte pas le mal c'est un
scandale entendu ça ouais ouais
sans quoi 0 1% on a plus de chance de se
faire shooter en bagnole ou en scooter à
paris que de choper le coc vis de
l'extérieur c'est à dire c'est très
clair ensuite regardez l'espagne
l'espagne à la ré ouvert avant nous
depuis maintenant mars parce qu'elle n'a
pas les moyens du confinement de riches
d'accord et sk raison tamis nation sur
partie non non et donc et si on vous
demandait et si on s'interrogeait mais
oh mon dieu que c'est dragon c'est grave
ce que je vais dire si c'est peut-être
les mesures que nous avons qui
conduisent à un recul finalement de la
progression de la décontamination en
quelque sorte leur dire je vais noté ça
sérieusement et si c'étaient les mesures
que nous avons maintenu de manière
stupide qui favorisait mais c'est sûr
que sous cloche
effectivement du virus il ya beaucoup de
gens qui animent la question de fabrice
1 mais je veux dire regardez les pays
qui ont libéré alors ils ont daksi nées
de l'arrivée qui sont vaccinées ok mais
pas forcément plus que nous pas beaucoup
plus que nous et finalement à un moment
donné et ben qu'on s'aperçoit de quoi
bein c'est que ces pays s'en sortent
mieux que nous alors j'entends
maintenant que la quatrième bague au
vietnam machin mais qu'est ce que vous
racontez
mais lorsqu'il est brûlé c'est pas le
professeur des assises et des amis au
festin mais ils viennent d'être des
confiné afin d'être composée des projets
d'éoliennes en mer
c'est un pays pauvre et meilleur accès
aux vaccins exactement mais attendez à
c'est peut-être leur chance au passage
mais c'est pas grave mais ça tue tête
avec un moment donné le sein droit
non c'est que tu es ce que je vis ces
choses que je m'évertue même à essayer
de vous expliquer que personne ne veut
entendre c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
baguette magique regarder la vaccination
elle a progressé on est d'accord
oui c'est mieux qu'à trois mois on est
d'accord et pourtant voilà cours
commencent à s'inquiéter avec des
départements alors qui est un
raisonnement recommencent à flamber
et qu'est-ce qu'on va dire il faut
vacciner combien 100 % de la population
n'ont qu'à nice a signé deux cent
cinquante pour cent pensent de maxine et
chacun à quatre doses non
non j'ai appris qu'ils avaient une
troisième d'audrey face d'avoir c'est
pas gentil pour les deux ans dépressif
important la vaccination des enfants
extraordinaires la situation et informer
les il faut vacciner les douze 17h10
présence d'un public
vous avez vu ce qu'a dit la chaîne s
aujourd'hui qui ça la chasse est là où
alex tenter le grand maistre est
français très chère très chère mais sert
pas à grand chose ça est intéressant et
pour la vacciner les jeunes alors ils
font pas d'efforts de grave donc sans et
d'amateurs mais pour empêcher la
transmission du virus on aux autres
ajoute ben en fait on regrette quand
même capable d'études de transmission
ségalis donc c'est la has
donc on verra pour le coup je voulais la
ville 1 donc on va vacciner des gens
pour se sortir d'une crise alors que les
jeunes contre les vieux mais on sait pas
si c'est vrai ce n'est pas grave quand
est ce qu'elle est très à l'aise ne
répondait pas toujours sans son avis la
de la presse etc sérieusement on regarde
c'est ce qui se passe dans d'autres pays
notamment en israël et c'est lors qu'on
peut aussi se passe en israël mais ce
qui arrive est ensuite leur sujet ce
poste en israël
dites moi ce qui se passe eh ben ils
font une large population vaccinée il
arrive un plafond de verre ou une parade
à bord et ça ne veut pas se faire
vacciner et ils ont dit qu'ils sont en
train de largement réouvrirait drop
alors ça hier soir largement réouvrir
vous trouvez vous non non non c'est une
question intéressante madame le portugal
ou la vacciner qu'on vient d'annoncer sa
série kings congrès où la météo est au
portugal attendait novak chez mai
maxime et professeures et professeurs je
fais de tout mais concourir sont bio
prend pas non mais j'ai marché pourquoi
aujourd'hui je veux bien je veux bien
qu'on se dise que ça n'a pas fonctionné
comme ça aurait dû que ça aurait pu
aller plus vite sur la vaccination qu'on
aurait dû faire mieux et m'a fait ce que
je dis mais ce qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
ce que dit fabrice viard fabrice di
vizio en fait dit que la meilleure
solution aurait été peut-être de rouvrir
plus tôt il est les deux d'avoir fait
tout ce qu'on filme en mai notamment et
notamment votre deux roues mais c'est
parce que je faisais moi et votre savoir
faire vous comptez le jeter à la
poubelle un jour vraiment pas excusez
moi je voudrais je comprends en fait
porte parole et donc porter une parole
compliqué et débile c'est pas facile
pour le risque vous attendez vous le
faites très bien ce projet la parole que
vous portez jeu la bassine de porter une
parole comme celle actuelle qui n'a
aucun sens parce que concrètement votre
couvre-feu madame on est tous d'accord
concrètement ça sert à rien là sur son
efficacité elle est complètement nul
la dir est tous les pays comme l'espagne
sur un couvre-feu effectivement d'un
minuit par exemple et bien s'en sortent
beaucoup mieux que nous ça vous
interroge pas c'est quand même question
quand même à un moment donné et puis il
ya un autre problème on parle de
quatrième bague mais je vais vous faire
un truc là je fais une prophétie avocat
prophète de temps en temps c'est pareil
si le ton face peut-être même avoir une
cinquième bague et peut-être même une
sixième et vous savez qu'on s'appelle
une épidémie merde alors merde alors eu
d'épidémie eh bien vous savez quoi on a
découvert un truc ont annoncé qu'une
épidémie c'est pas nous qui la contrôle
y en a qu'on peut faire ce qu'on veut
mais ne contrôle pas parce que israël
j'ai un truc à vous dire sur israël
quand même pas dire est intéressant on
fait dire vous savez qu israël est le
pire exemple que vous puissiez trouver
que ça et pourquoi qu'à moitié parce que
toutes les deux mais qui viennent
d'israël madame elles sont bidonnés
pourquoi c'est pourquoi ils sont
bidonnés parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
système officiel de pharmacovigilance
donc c'est absolument impossible la
langue le thé les plus fiables
mais israël n'a pas de système de
pharmacovigilance
on est incapable de savoir qu'elle soit
bien d'ailleurs qu'il est censé
pataphysique la cité dans le cas de la
france alors qu'en france on est en
train d'avancer massivement sur la
vaccination et les indicateurs
continuent à baisser malgré le fait qu
on est alors en salle et redire
les autres que toyota malgré le fait
qu'on est desserré les mesures de
restriction et la dernière mais voit
répondre aux bals et feux mettre des
vidéos aujourd'hui vous revenez
condescendant méprisant et donneur de
leçon je vous le dis la très franche
perfect fabrice je le respecte mais la
très franchement vous nous annoncez de
manière péremptoire et c'est dangereux
parce qu'il ya quelques pourcentage
infime mais quand même quelques
pourcentage de la population qui vous
crois hélas c'est dangereux parce
qu'après tout ce que je voyais et attend
des raisons d'abord s'était jamais
appuyé ma démonstration
j'entends prononcer des mots laissez moi
juste fait lire une seconde on expliqué
ils vous rappellent leur est vraiment
jouer sa parole juste après vous voyez
c'est un peu ça qui nous différencie
c'est que moi j'ai encore une infime
partie de la population qui me croient
vous c'est fini
[Applaudissements]
bâtard de fabrice alors que tu dois ça
moi je dis moi et on a donné des leçons
et quand vous dites à alcan couvre-feu
c'est criminel ce que vous dites les
gens les gens déjà ne respectent pas les
21h vous savez très bien les soirées ça
se relâchent si vous dites vous aux
couvre-feux les gens vont ressortir 23
heures non mais gilles là là dessus j'ai
j'adore prisca vraiment presque la norme
mais je suis d'accord annulant bride sur
le cou rohff à 21h ça favorise qu'une
chaussée les audiences télé non mais
franchement je vous dis la vérité ou
auckland où sont 69 ans est vrai que je
n'ai pas du tout respecté pris ce qu'un
pas il est maintenant je suis pas
d'accord faut des gens et à sa marque
infiniti ghoumal auriez des personnes
qui ne le respecte pas mes large
majorité le respecte et le sujet encore
une fois c'était de ne pas ouvrir de
manière trop rapide et de crise heures
maintenant nous l'évaluer mais je
voulais vous voulez mais vous dites la
majorité le respecte comment voulez
value mais il faut regarder ça mais
madame vous avez vous dit quelque chose
c'est comme normal qu'on puisse en
débattre français frère le mans n'a
donné suite comme vous je vivais vous
regarder je fête mon 70e du couvre-feu
bon mais le fait est que vous mais j'ai
donc moi je respecte ou non mais c'est
intéressant ce que m'a dit vous voyez
c'est ça que je reproche aux uns et aux
autres
vous parlez par affirmation vous avez
employé ce mot péremptoire c'est vous
qu'êtes péremptoire parce que vous
parlez du renvoi de 21h mais enfin et
jersey - monsieur verdez mais très
sérieusement des gens nous regardent le
minimum qu'on leur doit et rendent
passer un minimum de vérité vous n'avez
que le couvre-feu 21h ceci le batteur
cela mais donnez moi des éléments par
perdre sinon c'est du dogme et de la
religion
avez vous des éléments à ce sujet
l'épidémiologie monsieur sera respecté
et que celle et dangereuse qui rêve
d'être péremptoire le problème de fond
est toujours le même tout ce que ça veut
dire donc mais vous estimez que
finalement j'ai un mur et les
restrictions ont aggravé la situation
sanitaire de je pense que je n'en je
pensais encore une fois c'est là vous
vous trompez la différence de vous c'est
que moi je pense rien lâcher
il est pas ici pour nous est cher non
mais attendez je cherche et quand je
cherche à donner mais trouver quelque
chose
et les français nous avons une étude que
j'ai déjà publié ici il faudra vraiment
que je pense à vous les envoyer à venir
et bien je veux dire je le dis à la prod
que ce serait bien effectivement vous
aviez les études je pensais que j'étais
fait mais apparemment pas sur le fait ça
me met 50 qu'est ce qu'il a trouvé vous
héberge le tour de la question bonjour
et notre police et la parole wen ans
après ce que je sais pas on pose une
question j'essaie de l'atteindre ont
fait basique m'a pris ce séminaire ce
que j'essaye de vous dire c'est que ça
s'appelle l'effet pâte à modeler je
voulais déjà dit ça au coach ne m'a pas
dire que je voulais des abris restreint
les gens les gens continuent de vivre
quand même vacantes dans qu'est ce
qu'ils font ils font des fêtes
clandestines
ils font effectivement ils se réunissent
quand même et vous n'avez plus aucune
mesure de ce qui se passe est fait vous
n'avez absolument plus aucun contrôle
sur ce qui se passe c'est pour ça que
les écuries biologiste notamment
canadien dans une grande étude publiée
au jam à vous dise entre autres que il
valait mieux probablement pas
probablement inhalé mieux avoir des jo
sanitaires et touré ouvrir pour
contrôler ce qui s'y passe plutôt que
permettre aux gens c'est il avait ça les
fêtes clandestines là vous faites une
erreur c'est que vous pensez que par
l'effet de la volonté une espèce de
puissance créatrice
vous allez pouvoir empêcher les gens de
vivre oui mais ça c'est pas possible il
pas dû tenter toutes les dictatures on a
essayé on n'est pas arrivé donc c'est
pas en démocratie qu'on va y arriver
mais l'australie par exemple il referme
pour le cas mais l'australie mais le
sort ne comprennent pas donc sa vie à
les piéger et on évitera luc lauzerville
fait qu'est ce qui va se passer
le zéro kobe ça fonctionne avec un
pointe à nouveau à zéro c'est à dire
qu'à faire
non mais qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire et
regarder la preuve que l'australie
referme tout point cas et que c'est
quand même fou aujourd'hui il ya un
consensus international pour dire que le
confinement n'a aucun intérêt aucun
effet créé le président de la république
l'a reconnu qu'effectivement confirmé
les gens à l'intérieur n'avait aucun
effet et que c'est au contraire à
l'extérieur que la sécurité se
trouvaient et que c'était pas en les
enfermant à l'intérieur puisque par
définition le premier foyer de
contamination si le foyer familial
c'est l'intérieur pourquoi on a paré au
vert les salles de restaurant mais
plutôt les terrasses parce qu'on
craignait qu'à l'intérieur les gens de
scouts amine et donc vous voyez bien que
enfermer les gens n'a absolument aucun
effet productif et que je fasse mon
temps à vous de lire ici il ya
maintenant cinq six sept études mais y'a
pas pire sourd que celui qui veut pas
entendre parce que nous sommes dans des
ligues logis est en panne il est fini le
temps de la science il est fini le temps
de la raison ni les filles
moi je vais vous
comment ça va se finir des gens comme
moi qui ont les moyens de le faire vont
se tirer de ce pays aux états unis je
peux aller où je veux mais tu es classe
en ébène il s'est mis à fabriquer en
italie il ya un privilège c'est qu'ils
ont des règles matin ça ne respecte donc
bon on sait plus bien décalé vous
puissiez d'arrêter à rome pendant le
confinement vous et moi mais la police
et romain capitale qu'est la police de
rome
c'est bien ce que dira pas été capable
de faire mais les restaurants ouverts
parce qu'on a des trous un belge et un
cabinet arômes exotiques c'est le lot il
a le droit je l'avais l'année dédié au
mariage mais très irrité sur scène
quatre mois j'ai l'impression qu'on est
en train de tout faire pour que les gens
sombre dans la dépression en fait ça
fait quelques jours qu'on commence à peu
près là effet lors comment ça n'est pas
fini d'être dès qu'on finit qu'on nous
parle déjà de restriction de faire
attention de confinement faut arrêter de
prendre les gens pour des cons ça fait
des mois qu'on nous dit que cet été le
co vite ce sera fini là l'été c'est
demain c'est pas du tout fini encore des
masques y ait encore des couvre-feux et
je pense que si un quatrième confinement
les gens vont péter un câble qu'est ce
qui arrive et c'est bien car on en est
où la donne nous des bonnes nouvelles
ajouté karam et on y voit là non
très clairement on a pas reparlé de
confinement là c'est vrai petit ve ment
veut mettre les vidéos qui ont pas mais
dont ils sont beaux on est en train de
dérouler le calendrier de normal voilà
l'annoncé le desserrement des
restrictions on a commencé le 19 mai le
nem gens ça continue et le 31 et le 30
juin ça continue non je vois pas
pourquoi la tendance bien pour qu'on
nous dit alors faites attention faites
attention ça on va comme un signal mais
elle suffit pour ça que je dormais ses
attentions effectivement et cie a rien
de mal à dire attention c'est naturel
mais en réalisant que ce n'est pas non
plus aussi catastrophique que ce que ça
a pu être l'année dernière d'accord donc
lancé juste continuer à être vigilant
pour nous d'obtenir la pression bien sûr
on est à moins de 3000 personnes en
réanimation à 2600 personnes en mal
nutrition et de rien 16000 mes débuts
femme est l'égalé on est deux labos
concession était à 7 mai à cinq mille
cinq cent mille à cinq mille en juin non
je peux en novembre quand ça vous
comparez juin à novembre en mairie le
maire
mais dès mercredi on attendait excusez
moi excusez moi madame mais c'est vous
mais c'est pareil a joué la dernière
laissez moi parler en juin les dernières
on est en santé d'un vrai nom paul est
alors donc on ne peut pas comparer une
croix dessus
focus sur les monnaies mois imaginez
juste quinze secondes dans ce pays de
mission est de faire autre chose que de
prime expliqué sont pas fondées vous
donnez donc vous dit que le confinement
à une efficacité telle que l'année
dernière donc l'année dernière c'est
grâce au palais donc alors madame je
voulais un temps limité essayez d'aller
droit au but expliquez moi vous comparez
juin à novembre
c'est un problème donc l'année dernière
quels sont les chiffres cette année par
rapport à l'année dernière beaucoup
moins de cas l'année dernière 300
nouveaux cas le 1er juin je ne regardais
1200 nouveaux cas aujourd'hui requis et
avec ça on est derrière vous madame
alors d'alten best losers pourquoi
est-ce que le compliment est réussi oui
parce que de toute façon c'était
inévitable qu'on ouvre au bout d'un
moment et je trouve que d'ouvrir comme
ça c'est bien le fait de garder les
masques à l'extérieur même si on ne se
contaminent pas l'extérieur c'est bien
le fait de faire 21h05 l'erreur c'est
bien parce que je pense qu'on se
contaminent pas plus ou moins de 19 à
21h ou de 21h à minuit
mais je pense que c'est lé signal qui
font que les gens au moins théologique
son pardon des signes au final c'est le
dentifrice c'était ça au moins c'est les
signes on en fait c'est psychologique
c'est pour que les gens ne lâche pas
trop la pression de ses encombrants ce
masque que l'on garde les masses
colossales hors essence
les deux réseaux j'ai eu le temps de
faire et bien quand j'ai voulu de
commander à 9 heures réservées à 9h la
dame m'a dit venez à 19h30 parce qu'à
21h on ferme donc si les restaurateurs
jambert jeu
mais s'intéresse oui c'est d'aller fêter
samedi matin excusez moi et c'est très
intéressant ce que vous venez souvent
d'accord non mais c'est très intéressant
parce que c'est exactement vous venez de
démontrer avec puissance que je dis tout
à l'heure vous êtes dans la religion
ah ouais en fait je vous ferai dans la
région amène à b division civile bull
est ce qu'on peut caresser l'espoir que
ne veut l'arrêt ces personnes à risque
et services caresser l'espoir que le 9
juin
eh bien on annonce la fin mai comme les
chiffres sont bois paramore étudierait
le trucmuche et la reggina mais
reconnaissent à elle pour apprendre
n'est pas à l'abri d'une bonne nouvelle
mais pour l'instant à dont l'étoile abri
dont les non mais sérieusement enfin je
veux dire c'est assez désagréable parce
qu'ils ont en réalité on a tous ceux ci
on est content on s'enlise en les plans
les rigoles ou quoi être qu'on sort des
croûtons de quoi par exemple de quoi
juste écouter son acceptation de
débâcher d'échangés comptant beaucoup ne
vous ai pas besoin de coups de couteau
mais j'ai bel essai de paul est content
on est en sorte d'aller extrêmement
compliqué oui ça a été très compliqué on
est en train de sortir en train de
réouvrir il faut le faire de façon
progressive et de façon extrêmement
vigilant pour ne pas justement avoir une
quatrième classe quoi il faut être
content le rap n'est arrêté pendant les
voulait pas répondu à ma question est
comment ça fait il faut être content du
fait qu'on est en train de sortir oui
mais attendez il ya deux payer eux-mêmes
qui s'entraîne en fait servir l'histoire
du mec qui sait faire arrêter par erreur
qui est foutue rex et vous savez
création sortir quoi mais c'est
extrêmement content comme raisonnement
vous oubliez vous oublié quelque chose
d'envoûtant quelque chose vous oublié
quelque chose
c'est dommage mais on voulait quelque
chose c'est que la situation sanitaire a
été extrêmement compliqué vous voulez
peut-être pas parler des malades
peut-être pas des décès mais pensez
aussi aux soignants qui souffle au mieux
en n'arrête pas de travailler qui peut
bien venu encore aujourd'hui leur
travail est alors d'autant plus
d'après ces cas ont été relevés skieurs
pour une fois et qui continuent aussi à
se mobiliser sur les campagnes de
vaccination donc je pense où je possède
qu'un tout petit peu de respect et
d'humilité et les soignants c'est ce qui
vous avait distribué des masques ffp2
quoi y en avait que vous avez rappelé
parce qu'ils sont contaminés premiers
éléments dont vous mettez en danger et
soignants et ça moi vous donner des
leçons les soignants c'est moi qui les
ai défendu pour avoir les masques que
vous leur avez refusé chose est claire
vous êtes bien aimable mais le premier
procès qui a été sursouscrit c'est moi
qui les fais parce que vous ne vouliez
pas donné de masques de protection
soignants alors venez pas avec moi
aujourd'hui sur ce plateau me parler des
soies games et méprisé durant un an que
vous avez piétiné durant un an vous ne
vous avez qu à excuser moi excusez moi
je termine à mon tour que vous avez un
vêtement contaminés par ce que vous avez
envoyé à la guerre paraît-il sans masque
sans protection avec eux pendant que les
ministres se faisait tester les
soignants ne vais pas accès pendant que
les députés avaient des masques les
soignants n'ai pas accès alors de grâce
de grâce n'essayez pas avec moi de jouer
ce jeu là ça risquerait de mai dernier
vous avez aucune envie je m'énerve
deuxième point non vous allez cool quand
j'étais encore les points la deuxième
point je termine sur ce point les
malades madame les malades c'est ce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas trouver de les
animations que vous avez fermé que vos
prédécesseurs ont fermé c'est ça la
vérité la vérité c'est que nous sommes
devenus un état du tiers-monde par votre
faute
alors venez pas aujourd'hui mettre sur
mon dos les boas capacités venez pas
mettre sur mon dos et venez pas jouer nu
at on savait déjà
non non non non non non non non et c'est
le weed man et odile effectivement si
vous ne voulez pas penser aux malades
avec vos héros littéraire
excusez moi madame et les malades j'y
pense peut-être plus que vous est ce que
vous faites aujourd'hui on laisse cuire
en l'occurrence les soignants cdma la
dgi pente et soignez vous donnez jamais
pensé et les malades il fallait y penser
au moment où vous avez fermé les lits de
réanimation
vous avez fermé des lits de réanimation
entre mars et aujourd'hui vous avez
ouvert délais de réalisation éphémère à
sa quatrième dans le réfectoire pour ne
pas ouvrir des lits ferida sourire
maintenant à brice reprend peut-on
sauveteurs arrêtez de vous [ __ ] de moi
quand même presque arrivais pas en fait
vous allez respecter non non non j'ai
mis très bien madame c'est vous qui
comprenait absolument rien c'est ça le
problème est là fabrice c'est le patudo
grâce à la pression non non et non
pathos et on va pas venir effectivement
ça quand on m'a dit que je ne pense pas
aux malades à chaque forme sonate mêmes
arguments ni sac et quand on a pas
d'arguments à faire valoir sur le plan
objectifs et bah qu'est ce qu'on fait on
rentre effectivement dans le pathos qui
est le signe de la déshérence sur le
plan intellectuel c'est ça que ça veut
dire mais quel pays a réussi en
réanimation est ce qu'on italie s'était
même expliqué que l'union européenne a
fait n'importe quoi vous avez raison
alors qu'elle est réussie que ça puisque
je vais effectivement deux fois ni
plusieurs animations tout un peu moins
et que l'allemagne était en train de
s'engager dans un plan d'envergure de
turquie beaucoup payent les sims a
d'ailleurs fermé pardon les écoles
étaient fermées on confine à une caméra
non mais si notre aventure des écoles
enfin je veux dire
le problème est là concède la religion
nous avait une énorme étude italienne
une âme vous la voulez je laisse en
liberté un cadeau
maintenant je sais pas si je la fed a
prouvé que c'est ça que maintenant
attendez attendez
merci d'abord c'est ce que j'ai fait je
pense que ça ça les candidats liés je
m'excuse c'est une partie d'un recours
que mes collaborateurs sont en train de
faire contre l'autorisation de mise sur
le marché des médicaments pour le blé
des vaccins pour les enfants adacore
bien devant la cour des comptes dans les
balkans des vaccins pour les honneurs
mais je ne suis pas contre moi je suis
contre rien du tout je suis donné un
exemple on n'est pas en train de voter
pour ou contre c'est pas ça le débat le
débat aujourd'hui c'est que vous avez
des vaccins pour les enfants qui sont à
des effets secondaires absolument
épouvantable et qu'il faut bien que
quelqu'un s'en mêle de cette histoire
qu'on nous ment je vais voir l'étude
italienne mais tiennent bien sûr la
donne madame je vais l'apprendre mois
prenez-la aucune difficulté moyenne
m pour les anciennes études et non à l
effet secondaire pour les girondins
si vous pouvez notamment les vainqueurs
dit infectieuses par exemple vous avez
vu qu israël aujourd'hui dans la merde
noire de la centrale tandis en béton par
dont elles ont toutes été soigné ils ont
vacciné les enfants elles ont été
soignées c'est que les 250 4t sweeney et
alors alors donc effectivement il ya des
effets secondaires de myocardite mais
qui sont soignés dont quoi ils sont soit
la seconde citoyenne où les effets
secondaires mama les autres intérêts 7
secondes et soumettre des enfants
avaient fait seconde année vous accepté
de soumettre vos enfants à des effets
secondaires
alors on vaccination qui ne les concerne
pas coiffé la chine protège pas de la
démission ok chacun sa conception
l'autorité parentale et l'étude
italienne
je vais d'étudier ce soir vous devriez
vous devriez adorer la madame g au
profit de frais qu'elles s'adaptent
risque à ce comme ça à l'oral à quelque
chose
bakri bercy c'est important d'apprendre
que la fermeture des écoles sert à rien
ça nous éviterait de refaire un élément
voiture génère s'annonce et hainan la
csq assez pour vous mais parce que
personne ne lit rien je veux dire d'où
vient le personne ne vient vous êtes nom
du dogme
maintenant il faut qu'elle a dit ça et
ça a expliqué pour la vaccination des
enfants mais vous savez que martin kurde
offre qu'elle est spécialiste mondial de
la vaccination vous a dit qu'il faut pas
vacciner les enfants martyrs corner
harbin cuir 9 mai à vous a dit
effectivement qu'il faut pas dans
voudriez l'interné mais jamais à ça je
suis d'accord avec vous pour la saison
ne se contente pas d'un goûter des
enfants est il en train de leur team 12
et saison et ses blagues à vous
débrouiller comme aller faire un tour
sur la chaîne si oui de la vraie info
bagis a habité la fin vraiment que c'est
pas mon avis qui compte dans le terreau
de personnalités quand il est bien
d'interrogent pas une interview par an
c'est bien je te dis donc tu redescends
de 2,5 et amérique latine
mais ce qui est ce qui est vrai mais
c'est diviser c'est que nous on croit et
on pense et on réforme soit là on était
et vous vous aimez
lisez et c'est vrai et je pense qu'il
faudrait donner vraiment plus de crédit
à votre parole parce que à chaque fois
en rétro en rétropédale ans on sera
toujours content que vous aviez assez
juste jalabert qui a dit ça et c'est
vrai en fait c'est vrai on est dans un
truc c'est incroyable en fait et
aujourd'hui tout le monde donne son avis
alors que monsieur vient avec des piles
comme ça avec des chiffres encore en
phase de groupes des conneries non mais
vous dit pas que des conneries mais vous
refusez le débat et vous refusez d'avoir
de la nuance donc vous savez une session
avait amplement
je regardais ce qu'on pense et dit
simplement voilà on va regarder la
preuve là et comment aussi oui 47% non
50 cent pourrait s est mi figue mi
raisin mais c'est plus chic
voilà mais parce que en plus comme le
veau là pour le coup on va être d'accord
c'est pas fini et le calendrier est
encore en train de se déployer et qu'on
arrive jusqu'au trophée
donc je pense qu'il faut un grand
gagnant c'est la mobilité le 30 juin m
et au relais radio je ne serai pas seul
au entendu et que ça tranquillement en
train de faire de l'équitation avec mon
bel éphèbe